fijémonos en el grupo de las amigas y
vamos a empezar por asignarles un número
estético a este nitrógeno verdad y
recordemos que el número estético era
igual al número de enlaces y gmac que
teníamos alrededor de este nitrógeno que
en este caso tendremos 1 2 y 3
ok tenemos 3 y hay que sumarle el número
de pares solitarios de electrones que
tenemos en este nitrógeno que en este
caso vale 1 y por lo tanto el número
estético es 4 lo cual significa que
tenemos 4 orbitales híbridos y esto
implica que tenemos una hibridación esp
3 para este nitrógeno ok déjenme déjenme
lo marco tenemos una hibridación esp 3
para este nitrógeno
y de vídeos anteriores hemos visto que
una hibridación sp3 significa que
tenemos una geometría piramidal tribunal
para este nitrógeno verdad así que esa
es una forma de fijarnos en este grupo
funcional verdad y en ese en esa pareja
de electrones solitarios que están
localizados en este nitrógeno sin
embargo nosotros ya sabemos de las
estructuras resonantes sabemos que está
esta pareja de electrones en realidad no
está localizada en ese nitrógeno de
hecho está deslocalizada en resonancia
así que podríamos tomar esta pareja de
electrones verdad y empujarlos para
formar un enlace pi y así que esto nos
obligaría a empujar también estos
electrones y de este digamos en este en
este doble enlace déjenme marcarlos con
azul esto nos obligaría a empujar estos
electrones hacia el oxígeno así que
vamos a dibujar la estructura resonante
que obtenemos digamos tenemos
el grupo era digamos nuestro carbono y
aquí ahora sólo vamos a tener un enlace
entre el carbono y el oxígeno sin
embargo ahora vamos a tener una pareja
extra de electrones alrededor del
oxígeno muy bien ahora también tenemos
nuestro nitrógeno pero ahora tenemos un
enlace doble entre el carbono y el
nitrógeno el nitrógeno está unido al
grupo r y unido a este otro grupo r así
que ahora mejor deberíamos seguir en la
trayectoria que digamos siguieron estos
electrones verdad estos electrones
solitarios que estaban encima del
nitrógeno son los que ahora forman parte
de este doble enlace verdad mientras que
los electrones que se encontraban en
este doble enlace ahora se encuentran
alrededor del oxígeno como una pareja de
electrones solitarios
ahora si nos fijamos en las cargas
podemos observar que tenemos una carga
negativa ahora localizada en el oxígeno
y una carga positiva en el nitrógeno
verdad y con esto
de hecho recuerden siempre hay que poner
nuestros corchetes cuando estemos
hablando de estructuras resonantes
verdad
muy bien ahora vamos a calcular el
número estético para este nitrógeno ok
entonces tenemos el número estético
recordemos son el número de enlaces de
enlaces sigma verdad que tenemos
alrededor del nitrógeno así que aquí
tenemos un enlace sigma dos enlaces igm
a y recordemos que en los enlaces dobles
uno de ellos es un enlace sigma así que
tenemos tres enlaces y gmac y tenemos
que sumar el número de parejas el de
electrones solitarios alrededor del
nitrógeno que en este caso es cero así
que el número es teórico en realidad es
tres y eso nos dice que tiene una
hibridación sp2 verdad es decir esta
molécula tiene digamos digamos alrededor
del nitrógeno una geometría tribunal
plana muy bien
así que aquí hemos mostrado que nuestros
electrones están deslocalizados esta
está esta pareja de electrones en
realidad están deslocalizados debido a
la resonancia verdad y de hecho estudios
experimentales han mostrado que la el
grupo funcional de las amigas es plano
en verdad así que estos átomos
en realidad tienen una configuración
plan aquí lo cual significa que los
electrones en magenta que habíamos
pintado aquí no están localizados en ese
nitrógeno de hecho están deslocalizados
así que esto implica que este nitrógeno
este nitrógeno tiene una invitación sp2
verdad y tiene un orbital p que le
permite a esa pareja de electrones que
está en magenta estar deslocalizados así
que tenemos una situación en donde
podríamos dibujar una estructura
resonante verdad y eso nos ayuda a
descubrir qué es lo que realmente está
pasando esa pareja de electrones en
realidad está participando en resonancia
en lo cual hace que esté este nitrógeno
en realidad tenga una tenga una
hibridación sp2 verdad y que por lo
tanto tenga un orbital p muy bien vamos
a fijarnos en este ejemplo que tenemos
aquí abajo ok vamos a fijarnos primero
en el lado izquierdo de esta molécula
vamos a fijarnos en este lado izquierdo
de la molécula y en este lado podemos
ubicar muy bien nuestro grupo funciona a
la medida así que si nos fijamos en esta
pareja de electrones que tenemos en el
nitrógeno ok si nos fijamos en esa
pareja de electrones ya hemos visto que
esa pareja de hecho está deslocalizada
verdad así que de hecho puede participar
en resonancia y esto va a afectar la
geometría de cómo pensamos la
hibridación de este nitrógeno verdad así
que los electrones están deslocalizados
porque participan en resonancia verdad y
lo que está ocurriendo es que nuevamente
estos pueden formar un enlace doble
verdad con este enlace simple que ya
teníamos y esto nos va a obligar a
empujar este doble por bueno los
electrones que se encuentran en este
doble enlace van a ser empujados digamos
hacia el oxígeno entonces aquí podemos
decir que los electrones están
deslocalizados
deslocalizados muy bien ahora si
pensamos digamos del lado derecho vamos
a vamos a marcarlo digamos con azul ok
si nosotros pensamos que es lo que
ocurre del lado derecho y de hecho
déjenme pintar con azul estos electrones
o que entonces si nos fijamos en los
electrones de azul en la mina estos
electrones en realidad no tienen ningún
lugar a donde ir verdad no pueden
participar en resonancia esa pareja
solitaria de electrones que se encuentra
en azul está localizada en el nitrógeno
que esos están localizados esos están
localizados y realmente es por esto que
puede uno pensar que una amiga es muy
distinta a lo que es una mina en
términos de digamos como estructuras de
grupos funcionales y en términos de cómo
reaccionan y cómo se comportan ok vamos
a ver otro ejemplo vamos a ver este otro
ejemplo
si por un momento digamos pensamos que
esta pareja de electrones está
localizado en el nitrógeno vamos a
calcular su número estético ok el número
estético como ya hemos visto es el
número de enlaces y gmac que tenemos
alrededor del nitrógeno que en este caso
sería 1 2 y 3 verdad tenemos 3 enlaces
sigma y tenemos que sumarle el número de
parejas de electrones que se encuentran
alrededor del nitrógeno entonces tenemos
uno más y esto nos da que el número
estético es 4 y esto nos da una
configuración perdón una hibridación sp3
en ese nitrógeno ok pero sabemos que las
parejas solitarias de electrones en
realidad no están localizadas en ese
nitrógeno verdad esta pareja de
electrones está deslocalizado muy bien
de hecho estos los podemos mover hacia
acá
formando un doble enlace y eso nos
obliga a que este doble enlace estos
electrones que están en este digamos
doble enlace tienen que pasar
localizados a este carbono
y quizás debería poner en azul estos
electrones para que fuera mucho más
claro entonces realmente tenemos este
patrón que ya vimos en un vídeo anterior
verdad tenemos una pareja de electrones
solitarios digamos junto a un enlace a
un enlace junto a un enlace y muy bien
así que vamos a dibujar nuestra
estructura resonante vamos a poner
nuestra flecha verdad nuestra flecha
doble y hay que poner el bueno los
corchetes
muy bien
así que cómo quedaría esto cuando
pongamos el nitrógeno con digamos con
este hidrógeno verdad vamos a poner la
misma estructura cíclica
tenemos esta estructura cíclica y ahora
lo que ocurre es que los electrones que
estaban en azul van a formar un enlace
doble entre este carbono y este
nitrógeno y este doble enlace que
teníamos marcado con magenta ahora esos
electrones que formaban parte del enlace
doble se encuentran local y localizados
en el carbono verdad así que aquí en
este carbono tenemos una carga formal
negativa mientras que en el nitrógeno
podemos distinguir una carga formal
positiva muy bien vamos a cerrar los
corchetes y vamos a calcular ahora el
número estético para este nitrógeno que
tiene una carga formal positiva verdad
el número estético sería el número de
enlaces sigma que tenemos alrededor de
él que nuevamente podemos ver que son 3
porque en este doble enlace podemos
pensar que uno es un enlace sigma así
que tenemos tres sin embargo ya no
tenemos electrones solitarios alrededor
de él
que sumamos 0 y por lo tanto el número
estético es 3 lo cual nos dice que tiene
una hibridación sp2 verdad
y ya que sabemos esto esta pareja
solitaria de electrones en realidad está
deslocalizada y va a ocupar un orbital p
así que este nitrógeno verdad este
nitrógeno y ésta tiene una hibridación
sp2 porque sabemos que la hibridación
sp2 tiene tres orbitales híbridos sp2
verdad y un orbital p así que vamos a
tratar de dibujar esto ok entonces
podríamos pensar que aquí tenemos
nuestro nitrógeno verdad y aquí tenemos
un orbital p
tenemos un orbital p ok ahora bien los
electrones azules como estan
deslocalizados van a ocupar este orbital
p verdad
y de hecho estos electrones pueden
participar en resonancia ahora bien
vamos a terminar de dibujar algunas
cosas por ejemplo este este hidrógeno y
quizás aquí debería ser mucho más claro
que este es el nitrógeno verdad podemos
dibujar el hidrógeno y de hecho si se
dan cuenta pude haber dibujado muchas
otras estructuras resonantes pero bueno
por cuestiones de tiempo vamos a evitar
eso solo vamos a fijarnos digamos en
este ejemplo y si queremos terminar de
dibujar esta representación bueno
nosotros sabemos que cada uno de estos
carbonos tiene un enlace doble verdad y
eso significa que tienen una hibridación
sp2 verdad y si tienen una hibridación
sp2 cada uno de esos carbonos tiene un
orbital p que de hecho podemos ir
dibujando aquí verdad ahí está cada uno
cada uno de estos cuatro carbonos tiene
un orbital p que es el que justamente
estamos dibujando en esta representación
de abajo
y para ser más claros de hecho podemos
ver que estos electrones que voy a
todavía remarcar un poco más con rojo
estos electrones y están participando en
resonancia esos cuatro electrones rojos
que quemar que digamos remarcamos y
además estos electrones que tenemos en
azul que ocupan este orbital p están
participando en resonancia y esto va a
ser extremadamente importante cuando
estamos hablando de compuestos
aromáticos más adelante en este curso
así que por ahora sólo vamos a tratar de
obtener la habilidad de identificar
electrones deslocalizados y digamos
compararlos con los que están
localizados verdad en este caso los
electrones en el nitrógeno están
deslocalizados participan en resonancia
vamos a hacer un último ejemplo vamos a
hacer este último ejemplo y vamos a
empezar por calcular el número estético
para este nitrógeno nitrógeno perdón así
que el número estético es
nuevamente el número de enlaces sigma
que tenemos alrededor de este nitrógeno
verdad que en este caso son sólo dos
verdad sólo tenemos dos enlaces y gmac y
hay que sumarle el número de parejas de
electrones solitarios alrededor de este
nitrógeno que en este caso es 1 lo cual
nos da un número estético de 3 y eso nos
dice que tiene una hibridación esp 2
así que si tienen una hibridación sp2
ese nitrógeno va a tener un orbital p
así que vamos a vamos a esbozar digamos
ese ese orbital en este lado digamos que
este es nuestro nitrógeno verdad
entonces podemos pintar el orbital p que
tenemos en el nitrógeno ahí lo tienen y
de hecho pensemos en los otros carbonos
que tenemos en esta molécula verdad
tenemos estos otros 5 carbonos y si nos
damos cuenta cada uno de ellos tiene un
doble enlace que conecta con los otros
carbonos o con el nitrógeno en el caso
de estos que tenemos arriba
eso significa que tienen una hibridación
sp2 verdad y por lo tanto cada uno de
esos carbonos también va a tener un
orbital p de hecho tienen tres orbitales
híbridos sp2 y un orbital p que no está
hibridado digamos ok
vamos a ponerlo en la molécula
el orbital de cada uno de estos carbonos
muy bien
nos falta uno y lo mismo ocurre con este
nitrógeno verdad lo mismo ocurre tiene
tres orbitales híbridos sp2 y tiene un
orbital p no hibridado y de hecho ya
dirijan ya perdón ya dibujamos el
orbital p ahora vamos a poner los
orbitales e híbridos sp2 y vamos a usar
un color magenta digamos muy bien
digamos uno de ellos está formando este
enlace sigma que tenemos aquí el otro de
ellos se está formando el enlace sigma
que tenemos por acá
y finalmente tenemos un tercer orbital
híbrido sp2 que debe estar por ejemplo
por aquí muy bien
de hecho ese es exactamente el lugar en
donde esta pareja de electrones se va a
localizar verdad esta pareja de
electrones que voy a marcar nuevamente
con azul se va a localizar justamente en
este en este
orbital sp2 verdad de hecho déjenme
dibujar una flecha que indique
justamente en dónde se están localizando
aquí están localizados los electrones
muy bien así que esa pareja de
electrones en realidad está localizada
en este peor orbital sp2 verdad ya que
esta pareja de electrones en realidad de
hecho no puede participar en resonancia
porque el nitrógeno tiene ya un enlace
pi déjenme marcarlo con verde para que
sea mucho más claro con este en digamos
estos electrones pi que se encuentran en
este enlace en realidad ya están
ocupando este orbital verdad este
orbital p que acabo de marcar en verde
así que eso significa que los electrones
que tenemos en azul no pueden ocuparlo y
por lo tanto estos electrones en azul en
realidad van a estar localizados en el
nitrógeno que quizás es lo que no es no
es lo primero que pudimos haber pensado
verdad por qué
hemos hablado de este tipo de patrones
los electrones que tenemos aquí en azul
aunque esta pareja de electrones que
tenemos en azul están junto a un enlace
pi así que podrías pensar que podríamos
dibujar una estructura resonante la
razón por la cual no se puede dibujar
dicha estructura es porque los
electrones que tenemos en verde ya están
ocupando este orbital de verdad así que
digamos que podríamos pensar que es una
excepción a lo que ya hemos hablado
anteriormente cuando hablamos o cuando
dijimos que de haber una pareja de
electrones solitarios junto a un enlace
pi verdad esa pareja de electrones
estaría deslocalizada y hay que
considerarlo